le règne de Charles ne durera pas à
l'instant l'annonce du palais de
Buckingham sur la mort d'Elizabeth II
palais de Buckingham joue le livre tel
quel
famille royale
visiblement un problème de liaison nous
empêche de continuer depuis l'Ukraine
réaction de volodi mirzuelinski qui
envoie ses pensées et ses prières au
peuple britanniques
cette dernière a d'ailleurs publié un
message sur Twitter le pays entier est
préoccupé par les désolé il y a beaucoup
de bruit autour de moi et pour la petite
histoire la BBC il a annoncé après BFM
c'est ce qu'on a remarqué
[Musique]
Elisabeth II c'était un style à l'image
d'un renne toujours impeccable et bien
sûr inimitable
une garde-robe en emblématique
non
c'est pas possible je peux quitter
l'émission si vous voulez bah non reste
avec nous c'est si bien que ça là
franchement c'est vraiment tout ce que
j'aime plus qu'une coquetterie c'était
une manière d'assurer ses fonctions de
représentation auprès de son peuple
cet amour pour les couleurs refléter son
besoin d'être vu par ces sujets elle qui
était toujours entourée par la foule
lors de ses sorties elle devait être
visible est-elle toujours aussi lourde
oui
il est impossible de distinguer l'avant
de l'arrière
elle est très encombrante heureusement
j'ai à peu près la même tête que mon
père
cette tenue a été portée par Sa Majesté
en 2012 lors du jubilé de diamant cette
magnifique broche est faite du diamant
culinaire il a été découvert en 1905 et
c'était le plus gros diamant brut au
monde
cette broche est estimée après de 100
millions d'euros
[Musique]
2 complètement rock n' roll et c'est
pour ça qu'on l'aimait en Angleterre on
peut être on va dire prof la journée et
tant que le soir et elle elle incarne
vraiment ça notre reine elle est drôle
elle a toujours des punchlines
exceptionnels
impossible de baisser la tête pendant un
discours il faut la garder bien haute
sinon on risque de se rompre le cou et
la couronne tombe
et elle était très généreuse un jour il
y a un syndicaliste très très remonté
qui est invité avec une gamme et qui se
met à boire son rince-doigt et donc elle
a dit une ni deux elle a pris son
rince-doigt et elle l'abus pour qu'il se
sente à l'aise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vive le Royaume-Uni et vive la France